so you're in a deserted island which
grantchester colleague of yours would
you take along I would prefer to be by
myself
very hard
there's nowhere they speak Chinese
okay let's be Magnus sorry Gillings at
least like I believe some Vikings were
processorship
okay punish
at least I don't have to talk I just
turn them all and I sit back and chill
I guess Magnus because his uh he's
physically strong he could build things
I'm guessing if I had to pick someone
I'd probably say ding simply because
he's just mostly backed oh God I think
when you're standing on an island
you don't want to be bullied you want to
be the bully
so I think it's going to be good